pensez encore très peu sur le processus
comment on va les choisir ces gens là
pour ça qu'ils alimentent la sécurité
jour tu as ce processus là il est bien
avancé au moment où on se parle
céline quelque part dans des camps de
réfugiés au liban en jordanie et en
turquie il ya des familles entières de
réfugiés syriens qui ont été
sélectionnés par le canada et qu'ils le
savent donc imaginé un peu l'espoir sur
le terrain mais ce qui pour tenir comme
au canada le mot clé c'est sélectionner
le canada a le luxe de choisir se
réfugier contrairement à l'europe mais
on le voit depuis des années même des
mois qui compose avec l'arrivée massive
complètement désorganisée de milliers de
personnes qui traversent souvent
illégalement ils dont on connaît pas
vraiment l'histoire
la situation du canada n'a rien à voir
avec ça les agents d'immigration sont
sur le terrain dans ces pays qu'on a
choisi depuis des semaines ils
choisissent les réfugiés ils le font en
connaissance en pleine connaissance de
leur profil on peut écouter là dessus
françois audet il est directeur de
l'observatoire canadien sur les crises
humanitaires
on a pratiquement les curieux que les
curriculum vitae tout le monde on va
pouvoir choisir les gens éduqués
les gens qui parlent un peu le une ou
les deux langues
les gens qui sont des entrepreneurs ou
dans des jeux des entreprises donc des
acteurs productif de n'importe quelle
société
donc c'est un c'est un luxe qu'on a
de pouvoir avoir cette possibilité est
d'avoir cette information à la reste que
les gens se méfient on se questionne
beaucoup sur les mécanismes mis en place
par le gouvernement trudeau pour
justement éviter que des intégristes se
faufile peut-être oui pourtant ces
mécanismes là sont les mêmes que
d'habitude
le nude fourni des listes au
gouvernement canadien des réfugiés que
elle juge admissibles et ça s'est fait à
partir de deux trois quatre cinq
entrevues des fois auprès de certaines
familles où certains individus après le
gouvernement canadien les agents sur
place mènent leur propre enquête la
réalité c'est que sous le gouvernement
harper ont priorisé les minorités
religieuses et pas les syriens musulmans
pour les réfugiés musulmans ce que
trudeau a dit qu'il refusait de faire
don dont le franchement ça alimente
certaine crainte les gens font
l'amalgamé de plus en plus entre
réfugiés musulmans et terroristes c'est
ce que déplore monsieur trudeau obama
l'a dit aussi qu'en dans les faits toute
personne qui va monter dans l'avion au
cours des prochaines semaines pour venir
au canada aura fait l'objet de
vérifications assez serré au niveau des
renseignements plus brute encore une
fois mission d'elle la population qui va
venir chez nous n'est pas une population
à haut risque le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais je pense que le minimum qu'on
peut faire pour ces réfugiés le cdh est
accueillant sans pour autant négliger et
bâclé le processus d'enquêté de sécurité
et c'est ce qui je crois faire un peu
peur aux gens de drogba est ce qu on est
à quelques semaines près que de faire
venir une population ici ce qu'on va
faire les enquêtes adéquatement
pense que le canada fournissent c'est
oui et de tous les experts à qui j'ai
parlé ils sont unanimes de toutes les
étapes
la sélection le transport une
intégration de réfugiés la plus simple
c'est la sélection parce que
l'intégration
ce sera une autre et sur notre histoire
merci beaucoup tamara au revoir c'est
long